de stand en stand yoann est à la
recherche d'un architecte ou d'un maître
d'oeuvre qui pourrait l'aider à
construire sa maison mais sur des
principes qui respectent l'environnement
on souhaite construire une maison sur
des principes bioclimatiques
voilà donc une maison qui serait
autonome en énergie et qui serait
autonome en eau aussi que de la
récupération depuis changé de mode de
vie a en pris même si de plus en plus de
particuliers optent pour la rénovation
énergétique
les travaux sont conséquents et
nécessite une réflexion souvent les
artisans vous conseille de commencer par
les fenêtres ce qui est très coûteux
on a vite un budget autour de vingt
mille euros pour des fenêtres pour une
toiture la difficulté cela leur est de
savoir si on peut le faire par
l'intérieur ça fait quand même une
facture qui va vite monté autour de
20000 euros aussi et sur les murs et
tous et aussi de stores dhr là pendant
le salon l'association alex caille avec
la plateforme repères habitat propose un
accompagnement personnalisé aux
particuliers dans leur démarche de
rénovation
les entreprises partenaires de la
plateforme peuvent alors proposer des
devis aux visiteurs on fournit donc une
liste d'artisans donc ça peut être au
début dans un premier temps bureau
d'études et architectes pour bien
préparer son projet et ensuite tous les
artisans du bâtiment quand les travaux
sont terminés
on peut faire un suivi de consommation
et ils peuvent participer au concours
maisons économes on organise tous les
ans un panel d'entreprises étaient
présents pour proposer le meilleur devis
pour des visiteurs qui se sentent de
plus en plus concernés par la transition
énergétique